it's a war on poverty it's a war on
racism
it's a war on inequality it's always a
war why does the left love the language
of war so much
war requires top down control these
emergencies are necessary in order for
them
to once again centralize all power in
themselves
emergency breeds control for the left
and so everything is an emergency
as i've said the declaration by the left
that gun violence is an emergency and
therefore
the governor can literally just invoke
emergency powers that's dangerous stuff
as we'll talk about in a bit they do the
same thing with climate change climate
change is an emergency
therefore give us power we don't need
checks and balances we don't need
considered public policy we don't need
to battle this out
we actually just take control and we
solve the problem because the problem is
an emergency and the big public health
emergency of our day is of course
racism and the the art just gets longer
and rolls more as time goes on and as
the emergency
becomes deeper and more profound the the
left's argument is that america
is in the crisis of of race and uh
crisis of racial division reckoning a
reckoning
now normally when there is a reckoning
what that means is that the people who
are guilty pay right when when there's a
reckoning it means that somebody is
guilty and that person pays that person
has had a reckoning
in the united states the way reckoning
works is that we are all supposed to
take
blame for a bunch of crap that we didn't
do specifically so that people can
game the system and take control of it
that's effectively the argument that is
made
by the left these days and this
argument has now made its way in nearly
every major institution
in american society that we are
experiencing such an emergency
that all aspects of the institutional
structures of the united states
must be activated in order to fight this
emergency it's like world war ii
but with race right world war ii we had
to commandeer all of industry we had to
use all of it to produce the weaponry
necessary in order to defeat the nazis
world war
ii we had to regiment the population to
act in particular ways and make
particular sacrifices we had to hell
draft every
eligible man over the age of 18 in order
to fight in a war this is a war the left
loves the language of war you may notice
it's a war on poverty it's a war on
racism
it's a war on inequality it's always a
war why does the left love the language
of war so much
the reason they love the language of war
is because war requires regimentation
war requires top down control
now they tend to apply the term war to
things
that can never be defeated a racism can
never be defeated racism can be
mitigated
you can change legal structures to
prevent racism
from benefiting people for example you
can stop jim crow
but racism as a phenomenon in the human
heart can never be defeated the left
loves declaring wars you want to talk
about endless
wars and people talk about endless wars
in iraq and afghanistan those were not
endless wars but
put that aside the actual endless wars
are the wars the left declares we have
still not reached the end of the war on
drugs declared by the left in the 60s we
still have not reached the end
of the war on poverty declared by the
left in the 60s we still have not
reached the end of the war on racism
declared by the left in the 60s
why because these are things that will
never go away
and that's the point the more they don't
go away the more the war is endless the
more control you need
you know during the vietnam war lyndon
baines johnson engaged in a military
strategy
egged on by his idiot secretary of
defense robert mcnamara
of graduated escalation graduated
escalation was the notion
that we were going to instead of just
flooding the zone in vietnam with an
overwhelming number of troops and
thereby defeating
the vietcong quickly instead what we're
going to do is we're going to gradually
ratchet up the pressure and eventually
the viet cong would probably learn that
they shouldn't screw with us
well that didn't work but the notion of
graduated escalation
is exactly how the left treats
government involvement in these wars we
will gradually escalate the amount of
government control
and the goal there is precisely the
opposite of what graduated escalation
was supposed to accomplish in vietnam
namely the end of the war
here graduated escalation is supposed to
make you accustomed
to the government being more in control
of your life and to the institutions of
power
being shifted and and twisted into tools
of the government
so slowly you don't even notice so
slowly that the the
roots of ideology grow deep into the
bedrock of the foundational systems of
the country
and then it's too late to uproot them
it's too late to change them this is the
goal of the left
and when this is challenged people go
nuts well this is challenged people go
crazy and that's the current
debate that you're seeing over critical
race theory for example or teaching in
the schools
the left has spent the last 60 years in
this country attempting to infiltrate
every major institution
with radical ideas about what humanity
should be
and who should control other people and
now when it's challenged
they're very angry that you've noticed
they're very angry that you've seen it
and so they they are fighting back in
major ways or declaring that this stuff
is just not a big deal why are you even
noticing why is it even a big deal
and it is nearly every major institution
in american society
now i once again here pitch my upcoming
book the authoritarian moment it is
about this it is about how every major
institution in american society has been
weaponized and militarized
by the art and left over the course of
the last six decades
and how these institutions need to be
renormalized all it would have taken
is that apathetic middle standing up on
its hind legs and saying no
it's happening late but it's starting to
happen but it needs to happen because
the reality is the left continues to
declare
these emergencies these emergencies are
necessary in order for them
to once again centralize all power in
themselves
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wear are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment